the watch face is one of the most
prominent UI components of wear OS by
Google as a developer you can create
your own custom watch faces and share
your creations in the Google Play Store
I am Francois and I will walk you
through the high-level design and
development steps of the watch face to
kick off let's take a look at the
different components of the watch face
at its most basic a watch face is an
expression of style and provides a way
to tell time beyond this is also what we
call complications it's a traditional
watch making term denoting areas of the
watch face that show information other
than time in this example the watch face
is showing the date with wearer's by
Google being a connected platform watch
face developers can take full advantage
of data supplied by the system itself or
order apps installed on the watch this
enables watch face developers to display
bite-sized information right from the
watch face such as a current temperature
or other information that the user
chooses all those reporting
complications is technically optional
for watch face developers we have seen
strong user demand for this feature and
it is very much recommended lastly where
OS has two modes of operations
interactive mode and ambient mode in
interactive mode the user would expect a
watch face to be in full color and ready
for user interaction in ambient mode the
watch face should lay up no more than 5%
of the screen pixels and should avoid
solid blocks of color to prevent screen
burnin on the OLED display in addition
the screen is not expected to be updated
more than once a minute so remember to
remove any indication of seconds while
in this mode now that you have a design
it's time to start coding the easiest
way to get started is to create a new
project in Android studio select where
OS as the form factor and select watch
face after you have completed this setup
wizard you will have a startup project
with a functioning watch face that you
can customize in the generated code I
would like to highlight three methods
that developers should pay particular
attention to the first one is on surface
changed this method is run once at the
start of watch face creation and it has
access to screen dimensions as a result
the
is the perfect time to resize any bitmap
you might have or adjust the size of
your watch face features the second
method is on draw this is where the
watch face rendering code lives and it
runs every time a frame is drawn as a
result you should pay attention to its
performance avoid expensive operations
such as loading and resizing resources
last but not least on ambient mode
changed this is called whenever the
watch face enters or exits ambient mode
you can use this method to change and
swap paint objects before rendering the
screen as we mentioned before where OS
complications are a powerful way to help
the user stay connected by providing
bite-sized information on the watch face
we have a suite of api's to enable your
watch face to connect to external data
sources and help you render them using
complication drawables to find out more
follow this code lab with great power
comes great responsibility watch faces
are one of the most permanent UI
components of the wear OS platform at
the same time this means your watch face
will very likely be run for most of the
device uptime and inefficiency or errors
will severely impact battery and user
experience before you publish your watch
face please use it extensively for a
long period of time to catch any issues
pay particular attention to when the
watch is in ambient mode that it is not
doing more processing than it needs to
Anurag code could severally impact
battery life watch faces offer an
opportunity to create something very
personal and there is something special
about seeing your own watch face for the
first time on your wear device why not
set for yourself this might just be the
wearable platform for you
[Music]